so there I'm gonna pause for a second
just gonna stop this is the result let's
just apply it to this very very trivial
example here okay because we've just
shown this is not the way do it okay so
now here's what I do and I literally um
I literally actually go about this
process once I find my green I don't
have I go through this process when I
see a product okay I just designate one
of them you call that one you and then I
designate the other one V it doesn't
matter which ones which because a
product multiplication is commutative
ever change the order in this case U and
V are either once right and so now I
write out okay what is very--
you - + u v - okay well they sometimes
you'll see this written in Reverse
because addition is also commutative but
I think wolf sounds just marginally
better than so I can tell you this V is
X right
U is also X so what's you - it's one
right and then because these two things
are the same we're going to get exactly
- because U is X and V - is still 1
right and so there's X + H makes sure
enough is 2 X as you expected right how
would you do this is just a slightly
more complicated situation let's have a
think about for instance if I wanted to
differentiate let's do this x squared
plus 1 square root of yes I'll just do
that okay now we could we could expand
this out okay I could do that would be X
to the power of 5 on - I think somehow
half and then I could just treat it as
powder okay all right it's just
index Lola's hooray hey go ahead rap
you're drunk right now I could just
expand this but to get my head in the
space of how to use this theme for the
times when I can't just expand okay
let's treat these as at you and a me
okay so you designate one of them you
you designate the other one V and now
let's go through this V you - + u v - by
the way if you're gonna write this down
this is just another reason why it's
useful if you're going to write this
down then there has to be something
which is U and there has to be something
that's me if I didn't write this it's
like where did you pull that out from
you're a rabbit out of a hand okay so
that's to be justifying what's going on
v is the squared X okay you - what's the
derivative of this side it's just 2x
okay plus there's you okay and we
already established from first
principles that the square root of the
derivative of the square root of x -
Brett it's 1 or 2 X now you can
manipulate this algebraically and you'll
get you'll get there Tommy 2x + I'm just
tidying up the fractions okay you can
put this all the colors don't know
manator it wouldn't be that hard
shall we shall we quickly do it let's
see if we put this all over 2 root X
what would this pick up works this would
be 4 x squared plus x squared plus 1 on
to X and so I guess that's 5x squared
plus 1
I suppose you commercialize if you want
better it's Donny like I've done the
critical thing I've actually
differentiated and all this other stuff
is algebra and I'm not fussed about it
this question doesn't particularly go
anywhere like I haven't asked for
separate parts so I'll just go from
there I probably I think I think one
fraction is objectively simpler than 2
what's your terms I should say so I
think I think this line is superior to
this slide but you know it like I like I
keep saying this would simplify simplify
is is too generic a word to tell you in
every situation yeah you should have
this so you should have that you'd
realize when you first learn
factorization okay it's like Oh
expanding your factorizing sometimes
expanding is simpler and sometimes
factorizing is simpler kind of depends
on what you're gonna do with this result
so unfortunately I'm not gonna give you
a yes this or the other use your
discretion